la ferme aux oiseaux de réseau se situe
à quelques kilomètres de rambouillet et
le seul refuge pour perroquet en france
la deuxième structure d'europe en termes
de capacité de son oiseau et 62 espèces
s'y côtoient jacqueline à bénévole au
refuge
son préféré seppi qu un cacatoès à une
eu le plus joueur et le plus trouillard
de tous criard et destructeur il donne
la patte mais uniquement pour morges
il adore faire se mettre sur le dos les
pattes en l'air et faire le mort est
alors à moi la première fois qu'il a
fait ça j'ai hurlé picot picot et il
s'est relevé il a fait pipi que s'il
fait le mort c'est pour attirer
l'attention
entre sur le mauvais état dans le film
dit elle en arrivant au refuge
les signes et les raisons d'une mauvaise
santé sont difficiles à dessécher les
perrottet il ne supporte pas la
captivité et plusieurs années sont
parfois nécessaires pour les soigner
loisirs ont détresse passe d'abord par
une phase de quarantaine puis il est
placé à l'intérieur du refus c'est les
captifs ou en volière extérieur si les
sauvages le coeur de la journée c'est le
nettoyage et le nourrissage en les
stimulant leur talent à vue dans le jeu
on voit si mondiale on chante et on
danse en leur donnant à manger parce
qu'ils ont besoin parce que l'oiseau et
ils répondent à une altération s'ils
répondent pas ce qui n'est pas bien
surnommé l' prix gîte bardot des
perroquets and boisset leur consacre sa
vie depuis près de 20 ans au fil du
temps cette ancienne éducatrice et
infirmières pour autistes a su décrypter
leurs codes et comprendre leur
comportement
j'ai observé en ayant d'abord une tout
premier que ils avaient les mêmes
sérotypes dans leurs troubles du
comportement que les enfants autistes
quand ils sont stressés et donc là
c'est ça qui m'a amené à faire justement
cet engagement par rapport à elles les
mettent bien dans leur quête a essayé à
me blesser un rôle d'instructeurs pour
les vétérinaires et des étudiants
animalier elle publie un ouvrage le
perroquet 7,1 compris une charte de
règles à suivre
destiné à leurs propriétaires même si le
refuge ne se visite pas il est possible
de devenir adhérent et de parrainer un
perroquet l'association vient d'ailleurs
de lancer à souhait ce perroquet un
fonds de dotation qui lui permettra de
percevoir davantage de dons